hello we're glad you join us for this
live webinar metagenomics and base
modifications from long short and linked
reads I'm Alexis Corrales of lab routes
and I'll be moderating this session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Zemo
research corporation
Saima research corporation based on
Irvine California has been providing the
scientific community with comprehensive
nucleic acid solutions for DNA and RNA
research in epigenetics for more than
two decades the company's unique
achievements include development of the
first available Micro Aleutians thin
column technology for nucleic acid
purification in 2016
dyma research released there's Imoh
bionics line of products to help
optimize workflows for micro bionics and
metagenomics analysis their innovative
mock microbial community standards were
developed to validate microbiotic
workflows to ensure accurate community
profiling to date Zemo maintains the
most comprehensive products and services
for microbiome analysis to learn more
about Zemo research enzyme o bionics
please visit w-w-w can pose questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the present
Station window and follow the process
obtaining your credits I will now
present today's speaker dr. Burke
Christopher Mason
associate professor will Cornell
medicine world quant scholar and
director W Q initiative for quantitative
prediction and dr. shaquan tain
scientists i'ma Research Corporation dr.
Christopher Mason completed his dual BS
in genetics and biochemistry in 2001
from University of Wisconsin Madison his
PhD in genetics in 2006 from Yale
University and then completed
postdoctoral training in clinical
genetics of 2009 at Yale Medical School
at a joint postdoctoral fellow of
genomics ethics and law at Yale Law
School in 2009 is currently an associate
professor will Cornell Medicine with
appointments at the Tri institutional
program on computational biology and
medicine the Mayer center Cancer Center
and the field family brain and mind
Research Institute the Mason Laboratory
develops and deploys new biochemical and
computational methods and functional
genomics to elucidate the genetic basis
of human disease and human physiology we
create and explore novel techniques and
next-generation sequencing and
algorithms for tumor evolution genome
evolution DNA and RNA modifications and
genome epigenome engineering we also
work closely with NIST
FDA to build international standards for
these methods to ensure clinical quality
genome measurements editing we also work
with NASA to build integrated molecular
portraits of genomes epigenomes trim
transcriptomes than metagenomes for
astronauts which established some
molecular foundations and genetic
defenses for enabling long-term human
space travel dr shaquan tang is
currently a research scientist at zai mo
research he received his PhD in the
Department of Chemical Engineering and
applied chemistry from the University of
Toronto dr. chein joined John's mo in
research in 2014 and has since been
instrumental in the research and
development of Zayas microbiome --ax and
metagenomics program his past
experiences include work in the fields
of environmental microbiology and
biological process engineering with an
emphasis
on bioinformatics metagenomics and
anaerobic cultivation most recently dr.
Tang has been involved in the
development of Zima researches
microbiome X portfolio he has multiple
publications in different journals
including frontiers in microbiology
applied in environmental microbiology
and Philosophical Transactions of the
Royal Society of London series B
biological science for a full biography
on our speakers please go to the speaker
biographies tab dr. Mason dr. Tang will
now begin their presentations hello
everyone and thanks for joining the
seminar today where I'm going to
describe some of the work in our
laboratory and with collaborating groups
on developing standards and tests and
new methods for metagenomics detection
and for detecting base modifications
which can impact not only work we're
doing here but of course the very end
there's some exciting things we'll show
about using some of these methods and
standards for places as far away as say
the space station which is sitting up
above earth so first I'll start with a
bit of background of why some of these
this work is important is that if you
don't have good standards for anything
really that you're doing you can't
really measure things well or after were
you measuring things can you build them
well so I'll talk about both these
things today is that this is an analogy
would be imagine if you didn't have the
same distance between threads on screws
you couldn't build buildings or do a lot
of construction and this was true two or
three hundred years ago it took a while
for there to be actual standards but
once they were created a lot a lot more
comparability and uniformity of
construction also new things you could
just actually build and so some of the
background you know this kind of quest
to have better standards and metrics has
been borne up by editorials from Nature
Biotechnology to say that we need you
know better ways to characterize some of
the newer technology particularly in
sequencing and we've published a lot of
work on RNA sequencing to look at what
does this stander is for then dust
practices across platforms in this case
for you can see here some platforms for
RNA sequencing and now more subsequently
an ANA poor base sequencing and there's
a lot of excitement because you can now
let sequence RNA but of course you can
have a thousand dollar genome there's
been a lot of excitement also that this
is you know as of last year
you can get $100 genome sometime soon so
it's definitely an extraordinary time in
genetics and genomics but the challenge
is that you know we need more and more
benchmarks to make sure we're doing it
right so the update to the FDA studies
called the seq C 2 which is doing a lot
of benchmarking on on human samples you
can see here some of the testing designs
on going for these samples there's also
an interesting way that these cell lines
are being blended together so it's 10
different individuals that pools and so
we can see they're pretty large allelic
range that we can test for some of these
standards but that's just a quick update
on the DNA standards but one interesting
thing I want to go back to is from the
RNA sequencing data sets as we noticed
that even when you sequence things
really deep like say 2 12 billion reads
you know we can actually see that we
never really reach a real plateau we
keep finding new transcripts new
isoforms have really low levels you can
see on the figure on the right and also
it did depend on what gene annotation
used and that was true for RNA
sequencing and we know it'll be sure
also for some important DNA sequencing
in panels and rare mutations but what
was hadn't really been addressed then
but it's beginning to be addressed now
is the fact that you know there is more
than one genome of course and in our
bodies or there's been a debate about
exactly what percentage of cells are you
in terms of bacterial versus human but
we know there's a lot of them probably
about at least half of your body's
bacterial cells and you can see a lot
about debates literature but it means
really that there's a lot so if you were
to do this effectively and look at this
you know from from the view of the
microbiome you can see let's see you can
see here that the human cells are very
large but you're covered and generally
you know wash in these bacterial cells
if you step onto a scale it's about a
few pounds of your body is actually
bacterial cells so you can legitimately
blame them if your diet is not working
as much as you'd like the other thing
that the great work done by a lot of
people in the field like Curtis on our
and Rob dyes do define sort of the
commensals in the normal microbiome
human microbiome project but a lot of
this was you know defining these just
normal ecosystems which are important
outside the body but also inside the
body we know for example that about a
third of the small molecules in your
blood are either made by or traffic
through the microbiome
and this has important implications also
for how you look at human health so
including obesity or how you process
food or inflammatory bowel disease or
even other diseases that are related
even to mental disorders you can see a
list on the right of things that have
been linked to the microbiome to date so
it's really extraordinary time and the
microbiome is obviously very important
because you want to get if you have it
right a sort of microbiome force fueled
rather than something might be hurting
you can actually really give you a lot
of beneficial sort of protective
abilities for out competing other
bacteria and one great example this is
people microbiome transplants where you
can actually transplant an entire
ecosystem for someone who has a really
reticent infection that cannot be
treated well with antibiotics in this
case you can see this but a lot of
people even started to take matters into
their own hands with community action
groups like the power of poop comm which
is a I couldn't make it if I tried it's
an actual real website for people doing
things getting transplants on their own
but it's not because they're crazy is
because they're looking for something
that actually works well and so you can
see your success rate for c-diff
treatment is actually pretty pretty high
and so far one good thing is that it's
been regulated more as a as a tissue
than a drug which is helping some of the
transplants but but here too even with
all this promising power the question is
well if I do a transplant how do I know
it'll work or what I am transplanting
has Authority depended a lot on 16s
ribosomal RNA sequencing and you can see
here now from working gail rosen
Hirschberg is that if you say well if we
were to pick a gene today to define
what's in a sample where would it fall
if you pick different marker genes that
are present in almost all bacteria that
you can amplify and you can produce a
amino acid identity or compared to say
general similarity of distantly related
prokaryotes are closely related ones you
can see 16s RNA is really you know you
wouldn't pick it today if you were to
pick again from scratch a marker gene
that you could use in bacteria and
archaea it's you know it's an okay
marker for distantly related procare's
but not really at all for closely
related ones and you can see here some
examples we have problems to the
phylogeny defined by 16s and so it seems
I think it was really just a useful
accident of history that we could define
ecosystems through the lens of one genes
one gene but we know now that you know
there's many other things you can see
from shotgun sequencing which we prefer
for all these reasons listed here as
things you can
start to pull out from the samples it's
a bit more expensive but that cost is
coming down and we've already seen some
utility in the fact that if you do
shotgun sequencing of all ice let's say
from a clinical and not ICU you can see
here that what you normally think of
you're culturing you might have one kind
of strain you actually many more sub
stratification of what you've detected
from a clinical sample so which is
exciting but still comes back to the
original question is you are really good
at measuring can we really reach what I
think is the precision metagenomics that
you don't necessarily know where any
sample came from but you want to make
sure you've measured it correctly that
you know what is there so one
interesting chart we've made and it just
published this in a paper I'll talk
about that a few slides is you can
change how deeply you sequence the
sample menu sub sample you'll keep
finding new species as these sequence
deeper very similar to the chart that we
made for the FDA first study in 2014 and
what's interesting though is if you do
it based on pathway analysis of what's
present say from eman pathways that does
you know it basically give you some more
consistency as a function of depth but
it's still not perfect and so this has
led to some work through NIST which is
called the microbial standards group and
international metagenomics and
microbiome standards alliance or insa
and to date we know there's at least 71
computational tools for profiling
microbial communities so we decided to I
do a little bit of a comparison with
this paper we just published last fall
which is looking at depending on what
your goal is are you looking for
sensitivity or specificity you know what
are your key metrics you're looking at
measure these classifiers based on this
gives you kind of a chart here but one
of the take-home points is that across
many of the tools we looked at if you
look at the genus level it's not too bad
but if you think it's species or you go
down even sub species level the strain
level identification is still one of the
really hardest challenges from chocolate
sequence data but is also where the most
important factors are to be measured so
this is well the most difficult perhaps
still one of the most important so one
of the reasons that we published this
paper was somewhat just for our own
erudition to know what to do but also we
wanted us as a place to go for people
who are looking for good standards and
benchmarks and voila curated and
annotated and titrated if possible
datasets and samples and moreover that
you know we don't just want to sequence
them we want other people to order them
not just today but also in the future
and so one of the datasets in here if
you go actually you know if you look at
one of the challenges with one of the
more complex datasets we saw four long
ten differences the number of predicted
species from one of the complex samples
but there is no standard for a place
like this and there was no really
standard for really a complex situation
like this for example but we did you
know Inc you know wherever you're
looking a really strange place like this
is the Gowanus Canal Superfund site you
need to know that you're at least have
titrated positive controls and that's
one of the reasons MF in that paper the
bio tool is the name of the file but
it's actually the design mabye omics
control was there early name of the
product and it is actually now a
standard product and so when looking in
really strange places we want you know
standards if that includes for example
like some ways which I'll talk about
briefly but we really have a question of
you know who's there and what are they
making and to do this like any good
experiment you do need some control so
to that end I want to describe some of
the work that we've done in a lot of
them very close concert was i'ma when
they were when I met some of the people
from cyma was saying they wanted to
develop a titrated standard of bacteria
and yeast I thought well that's
fantastic because it really didn't exist
or what was out in the field you could
only order a very limited amount of it
so you know to give a quick snapshot of
what's out there this is again a very
focused effort from a group at NIST and
several academic and industry groups
working together to develop these
standards there are there's more than
one just to be fair there is one from a
TCC that was released which has been
characterized and we know that
essentially to change what primer that
you use you can see different versions
different proportions of general
depending on what region of the 16s we
look at so we know it's very important
and zai mo by omics actually when they
release their standard this is I think
to my knowledge the first really multi
Kingdom standards of both bacteria as
well as yeast you can see here put
together different GC different
abundances present that are titrate
in together so you can utilize and we've
been using this for now almost three
years because we can use it music and
almost all our experiments because it's
really like any good experiment you will
need a positive control and so we've
seen we've until we've published one
paper on this we're looking at different
numbers of cycles of PCR to test on
different for example in this case Qaeda
gene or Illumina library perhaps so this
gives us this is not analyzed with one
codex here you can see and it really
gave us an immediate readout of you know
is it working are we doing well does the
data look about right and so in this
case we can see very much we were
expecting to see the Cryptococcus and
the sacrum i sees a low abundance and
the other ones that generally equal
abundance you know again not perfect but
it gives us a sense of what's the
technical noise at the bench what's the
noise the computational side and
anything in between and so we can see
here that pcr was not our big variable
we do know you know you can see these
species pop up but we know that also
different protocols and this came up a
little bit from work that dr. Tang is
does that you know different protocols
we know will give different yields of
what you do theoretical output from some
of these organisms so this is another
reason to have the control not only a
DNA form but also in a cell form so you
can do this kind of testing and so this
is another reason to have these these
controls and so we as I mentioned before
all these guys that we put out there
from the paper from Alexa McIntyre's a
grad student a lab is all publicly
available they're there for people to
use for their own testing of algorithms
or methods and really they're because
mostly built because I wish they had
existed when I started working a lot in
metagenomics and so it's the first
beginning stuff to have some of these
standards out there one of the note is
that we did also just released a
preprint so this is 10x data so chromium
data using design mode controls so
they're pooled together and the data
here are publicly available we just put
in a preprint join you can actually use
10x reads to generate these read clouds
to you know try and stitch together in
each individual molecule which species
it came from and we've also released
code called minerva which is open source
and publicly available from davidenko as
a grad student a lab to do deconvolution
of these long reads that are synthetic
long reads from the molecular barcodes
and so that's again about
people to use so what we're doing with
all this that's kind of at the backdrop
I'll tell you a bit about what we've
been doing so the big question is you
know what have we been missing one of
our big questions that lab has what
we've been missing for example what's in
urban microbiome or what The New Yorker
called in the trap alone but in some
work we've done and you know this is
looking at microbiome of cities this was
also announced as part of the National
microbiome initiative and is sponsored
by the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
but it's a project we have called
medicine which we build these genetic
maps of the Earth's cities as a way to
track antimicrobial resistance and also
to mind for new biases like gene
clusters and in every city we use the
controls of zai mo for positive controls
during sampling and processing for all
these samples so what this looks like is
I don't know if the video here renders
but it's a planet you can see what this
means is we've been sampling since 2015
and basically sampling around the world
to generate sort of a global map of the
earth cities and what's present
metagenomics wise so this ends up
looking looks like a lot of shipping we
do a lot of this every summer on the
summer solstice we do a global city
sampling day you can see here as the
samples leaving lab dad many places like
Marseilles France to Tokyo Japan you can
see here some of the collection tweets
are very fun a lot of people after
sampling end up drinking beer at the end
of the day this is we find this to be
very common
Bettis type occurrence we have teams in
Singapore also doing a salt air sampling
San Francisco working with Jessica green
in Bogota you can see here of course in
New York City and then in Kiev and then
Lima and you can see here Minneapolis
with some Vikings Allison Denver and
then finally other places like Fairbanks
and Doha you can see and then this year
we got the first mayor own we had a city
council members helping us in New York
City but we got Catherine Pugh the mayor
of Baltimore
actually out swabbing this past summer
which is really fun you can see her
appropriate perplexed looking face there
during the sampling but again in all
cases as I know controls were behind the
efforts to do the probing and so one
thing we've seen so far for example is
that there's a really wide diversity of
the anthemic resistance markers
particularly in New York City and we're
expanding so now
to the other cities and we can see so
far that there is some stratification of
different cities around the world as
what we can see for both their
methyltransferases that are present but
also just their AMR markers that we can
see you can see different cities around
the world fear color do show not only
some degree of clustering based on
geography but also we can see different
highly abundant antimicrob resistant
markers in different areas of the world
which is something we're using to track
when we're the most abundant ones are
appearing and then how they're moving
and also we seem that this data has been
useful not for our sake but also other
groups have been downloading our
publicly available data to extend expand
out the Tree of Life to discover new
branches on the tree of life which we
find that really exciting so so one
another idea we had is you know what if
we kept doing this not just around
cities but if we started doing it for
example of conferences so recently at a
brief meeting this past year we actually
swapped everyone's phones and basically
wanted to see what would happen as on
people phones that you're at a
conference so this involves setting up a
sampling basically paradigm or we didn't
get much sleep but collect samples at
the meeting get them over to luminous
headquarters do library very quickly do
some quick analysis and then want to
make report at the meeting 36 hours
later so everyone could look at their
sample not surprisingly we use the
positive controls from Zemo during this
experiment to make sure we're seeing
pretty good controls which indeed we did
here and we really use the soy to
generate hypotheses about what people
were doing at the meeting kind of where
they'd been so like for example could it
review what you've been eating or doing
and here we think that we saw a lot of
human DNA and some unknown but a lot of
bacteria you can see here's our two
positive controls but some people had
really high amounts of unknown DNA one
person maybe appeared to be alien ish
because we couldn't detect a lot of
their DNA didn't match anything known
but we did see other interesting trends
for example across food and pets we saw
some things pop up from people and then
want to say well is that really what's
it's matching and so we asked this
person to be an orange and he said it's
okay to reveal his name he said yes
indeed I just peeled an orange before he
gave us his phone one person looked as
if you had maybe pork or bacon and
indeed this is a guy who had just used
the phone to take a picture of a pulled
pork sandwich he ate the night before
that was still apparently
phone we also then looked at other
comparisons of what is the cosine
simulator to known by sites and choose
look the least liked skin but a lot of
other samples do look like skin and we
could also see a little bit of a signal
for people who say they have cats and
for people who had dogs a much stronger
signal that was present so it kind of
serves as a forensic tool as well as a
discovery tool from the shotgun
sequencing which was kind of fun and of
course we saw antibiotic resistance
present in a lot of people's phones
which is a we find pretty commonly in a
lot of places and also one last but if I
pothinus this generation is that we
could see you know basically people who
just taken antibiotics had a pretty
different profile from those who didn't
and maybe enriched for Hema Phylis
organism which we thought was kind of an
interesting hypothesis from the data so
that's what we've been doing it and sort
of sequencing everywhere on earth but
where else could be sequence one of the
last projects on telling what about is
what are two specific projects that
we're doing in space so one is doing
participatory medicine with twin
astronauts so we've been studying for
the past few years
Kelly twins in this case we're trying to
understand the impact of space travel
and human body as well as the microbiome
and that's called the NASA twin study
and so a lot of these results are
embargoed until a few weeks from now but
they'll be more data coming out soon
once the papers come out but we do see
some changes in spaces you can imagine
in the microbiome but one thing I can be
that we just published I'm happy to tell
you about today is a lot of work we did
with Erin Burton and Sarah castor
Wallace at JSC Johnson Space Center and
others at NASA to think what could we
were sequencing space and could we get
these standards to work in space we
actually of course NASA when you start a
project and say you need a patch as we
were planning the mission we had an
issue where one of our resupply rockets
exploded on the way to the space station
so we've got this though really nice
letter saying or I did saying sorry that
we blew up your supplies and we're going
to urge you to continue your inquiry and
make sure that we get our supplies up
there which I thought was very touching
actually and as we had a chance to do
work on the parabolic flight simulator
we could actually see could more the
nanopore sequencing work and zero
gravity and this is a video of XE Andy
Feinberg doing testing in zero-gravity
which was very difficult but I can tell
you did eventually work we're sure with
a load of live around at the flow cell
and it sure that was possible to
sequence in zero grab
and this basically also led doing a new
algorithm to analyze the data and
eventually was published last year and
then right around the same time dr. Kate
Rubin's was getting ready to go up she's
a trained virologist to go get the first
sequencing in space she made it up there
no problem and also we know the resupply
mission worked well eventually we got
actually the first sequencing in space
to work forever from the very first time
and we got not just one run we got
dozens of runs to complete what some
called the dawn of Jemison space and
then also got out to a billion bases
sequence so one of the exciting thing is
known did it work it actually worked
really really well we could see at the
time at least as we very good data we
could see in space in zero gravity from
e.coli and Nelson and lambda DNA look
very very good and we got even as good
or better data in space than we did on
earth for the same control library so it
looked really really good and we just
publish this at the end of December sort
of the first genome sequence and
unassembled offers you can see here from
work that we did with collaborators at
NASA and one really exciting thing that
happened as a consequence of this is a
when they start to think about future
missions after we were finishing with
out of there the NASA saying we need
more controls and so actually just a few
weeks ago there will be using that for
sequencing and actually doing library
for in space and the controls that we
use during the development of this were
indeed design will control so they have
made their way up to the space station
and are now truly kind of both
earthbound and space bound per space
flying controls which we are using not
only for some of these studies but also
and I'm going to work for the SECC to
now include some of the syma controls
that we're using to characterize what's
present in them so to this end we've
clever not just with the FDA with the
SECC group but also with the Argos which
is the reference grade bacterial strain
group led by Heidi shifting and and you
can see we've been sequencing unpacked
bio and Oxford nanopore each of the
individuals friends from Xiamen were
almost done with the final base
modification detection and we'll be
releasing all these data very shortly
again in close collaboration with mo to
just you know establish these controls
and so I can give you a little bit of
preview of what we've seen
so far so in particular you know as many
of you probably know methyl 6a is a very
common modification of adenosine found
especially in bacteria there's some one
of the first datasets I looked at this
and we've developed a base color for
Nana for sequencing to call epigenetic
modifications in Nana Poor Dad and
particularly look at is the current
information the deviation from expected
currents is to the training run versus
the test run for rhythm called n color
and you can see certain positions as
they move through the poor more
informative than others so for example
the fifth position you can see here is
much more informative to differentiate
m6 favors a from our data and we've
tried a variety of different machine
learning methods to see which ones would
be the most effective and gotten out to
about ninety forfeiture accuracy with
some of the methods that we've tested
and what's really exciting as we started
comparing these two fact bio data we
could see there are known motifs for
where you should see based modifications
in these reference strains and we can
see for PacBio versus Oxford nanopore
using design most strains that we can
pick up some interesting you know new
motifs that are present in Oxford
nanopore data that we didn't quite pick
up from the fact bio-data where it looks
like you know it does have a signal
where you can see the canonical motif
versus not where you get the quality
value for the base modifications but the
signal seems a bit stronger for the
Oxford nanopore data at least for these
sites so far so it's interesting having
these standards because now we can have
you know two different metrics defined
in principle all the base modifications
that are present in these diamo controls
the next thing we're doing again these
dead will be released a relatively soon
we're just finishing some of the latest
version of the base modification quality
PacBio and it will release all these
likely by a G BT or maybe a bi meaning
so within a couple months and again for
people to use as a part of their own
development for tools and methods I mean
the long-term view of course is not just
to measure things but to then start
using them as a way to build things and
so engineering genomes
used to because somebody could really
couldn't really do that easily or that
well but it's already been done you know
for human genomes and human embryos have
been edited entire you know Pig systems
have been edited so you could grow human
transplants in them this led to a lot of
discussion about a synthetic human
genome
a project called genome project right
which I'm working with many people
listed here and developing ideas around
this but but the principle is that
understanding biology I think is best
measured by can you engineer or tweet
something and then actually predict the
outcome so we've been talking a lot
about even engineering defences genetic
defenses to be internal to astronauts or
at least on their microbiome on the
outside is another idea that's come up
because they interface for example in
the space station with a microbiome all
the time it looks like this it gets
moldy it's just like Earth in that
regard that you have many complex
interactions and exchanges of microbes
all the time and so modeling and
measuring them and eventually even
engineering them to be more protective
and more commensal like would
potentially be a very good thing for
them especially in that limited
environment with limited abilities to
counter axon and that goes wrong so
that's a bit background sort of what
we're thinking about for NASA but also
again these controls we've built we've
been mapping as part of them the what
are the methyltransferase is present in
each of the silo strains from these
controls and mapping these out again
this preprint will go online likely very
soon but we can see it's not just you
know what they have for you know you
know just interesting genes that are
known function but all the biochemical
capacity of what methyl transferase they
have another may or may impact virulence
or even just by adaptation to space like
environments is something we're keeping
it on for so in the long long run think
about engineering not just a space
station but even at our planet some
people at NASA talk a lot about
terraforming or going there for long
term missions and this does seem strange
to many people to think that far out but
I think it's actually not that different
from what we already do on the first
planet Earth where we think of planetary
scale monitoring and really mitigation
of any things like climate change or any
issues on the planet speciation and the
conservation so this is just really the
second time I think we're doing so in
the end I want to thank thank you
everyone for attending also state the
life evolves and clonality shifts at
check and epigenetic layers we see a lot
of skin and unknown back DNA in the
subway systems in the medicine project
but we see a lot of potential vas that a
gene clusters we can see what you've
been doing on your phone designo
controls have been
really no globally or even sub sub
orbitally low Earth orbit used controls
for all these genetic applications and
we've really enjoyed using them and also
we know we can actually sequence on the
space station the nanopore sequencers
action are validated piece of flight
hardware so if you submit projects to
announce that you can just request to
use it and it is yours to use but I
think everyone in the lab what makes all
this work possible and really makes it
possible for me to tell you about things
that we're doing and great thank of
course there are Kelly twins for their
blood sweat and tears to make this
possible this is their official NASA
poster and of course many collaborators
who helped with the medicine project
Consortium for spaceships from Harvard
clevers from JPL and UCSF now so funding
from NIH and Gates Foundation and NASA
and world quantum bailey and several
others and this is thanks to everyone in
11 climbers and thank you very much for
your time
thank you dr. Mason for that informative
presentation I will now turn it over to
dr. King for his presentation hello
everyone my name is Cheech intenso I'm a
research scientist as i'ma research the
data topic of my presentation is
improving the accuracy and
reproducibility of microbiome
measurements so this is a brief outline
of my presentation
at the beginning I will talk about the
issue of bias in the field microbiome
mix and then I would talk shows some of
our experience and also examples about
purchasing bias in different step of
micro bombing workflow in the end I
would like to introduce a new product
from us it's actually a new microbiome
standard they can help you assess
accuracy and also detection limit signal
tendency so as you know in the past our
decade the field of microbiome Ickx has
been developed rapidly and it has great
greatly our change our understanding
about microbiology and also how microbes
interact with human beings and at the
beginning of this talk so I would like
to talk about our
the problem with the bias issue in the
field actually at while at the beginning
of this field this field has also been
criticized for poor data quality and
pull data with the disability even even
the biggest prayers in a few have
reported contradictory results here I
will give you an example just to
describe the problem
the first is story published in science
news of 2014 and he also is free or once
to a sample into two and semi each of
them to each of the two armed our most
well known microbiome arm profiling
organization American car and you biome
and but surprisingly the microbiome
profile coming back from these two
organizations ultimately different the
profile from American gossip says
there's about a 60% of arm
Bacteroides while the profiles from the
you by own sets the Vickie Roy Diaz is
only about it's only about a thirty
percent and this is a problem we need to
overcome the the second example is even
more striking so the human microbiome
project and also their medical project
are two modes of other two biggest
project they have ever conducted to
profiling human gut however there are
interpretations of the human gut
microbiome are actually quite different
so this profile shows this figure shows
the average profiles of the human gut
microbiome determined by these two
projects and as you can see the truthful
profile looks dramatically different the
question is a lot of difference we seen
here are this difference will or are
less difference biological differences
or technical differences this is a paper
published in 2014 he also the in the
in the paper the author's compelled the
electrician kids from went ahead and
a-anne HMP and actually found that the
DNA instruction process use in this
project can actually dramatically change
the other microbial profile in the air
so if you know about how microbiome
profiling was done you would not be
surprised that there was a huge problem
of bias in this field this is because
the microbiome egg waffles are
complicated and each step at each step
bias or artifacts can easily introduce
and causing actually microbial
measurements so this slide shows
different factors that can easily
introduce into a workflow and the the
microbiome measurement is actually
required to be both quantitative and
sensitive and the ideal microbiome
workflow need to be unbiased and free of
contamination however this new
requirement was not taken into
consideration when tools or any one
tools were designed for microbiome
research because of that new innovations
and new tools need to be utilized to
improve our them to improve the accuracy
of microbiome measurements so next I
will show some examples and experience
of how we use how you some tools to
prevent and address bias during a sample
connection and preservation as the first
step of the microbiome in workflow
sample connection is of critical
importance because any potential bias
introduced in this step will carry over
through the whole pipeline and affect
the final results and as you know a
microbe yolk of sample can change easily
after summer connection you two are
undesired microbial growth or arm of a
nucleus integrated patient and in many
cases assess to refresh
raishin or freezing is not available so
there was a urgent need for Co free and
unbiased method to preserve microbiome
samples so this is also we did
experiment this is a this is the prof
this this figure shows how the microbial
composition of a theis example can
change um we save a room temperature
without protection and as you can see
the change already happened in just one
day so our solution to prevent our
buyers during the sample connection is a
is a product is a new product called DNA
initio which when added to a sample can
stabilize both DNA and RNA profile at
room temperature for more than one
months so this figure shows the
microbial composition of a PC sample 7dn
on this year and samples over the course
of one month and as you can see the
microbial composition stayed almost
constant table if affordable many people
would still choose to choose to use
freezing to preserve microbiome samples
however our there was a problem but
however even with freezing there's a
potential problem they can cause bias
for example in the literature and there
is there is an there is a recognition
above our potential buyers of Lukumi
introduced by freeze or cycling so we
did experiment to confirm this potential
problem so we took a PC sample and let
it go through our frequent cycles Oh
five cycle ten cycles and and as you can
see by go by five are as you can see
equal to five cycles of resource i crane
and can cause the some dramatic change
in the microbiome profile and that is
sorry um that can go through a dramatic
change of microbiome profile and
actually the analogy is also a solution
to prevent this problem these profile
shows all DNR natio are awesome for
saving the announcer and let it go to
the recycling process and you can see in
this case the bacteria DS is protected
in this case so next I will talk about
how to potentially address bias viewing
DNA extraction process on the step of
DNA extraction has long been known to
cause fires on during microbiome
profiling so in this case we comparing
four different in exertion Pro Tools
using the demo bar McMichael vo computed
standard as a defined input and this of
these four TN exertion protocols include
hours i'm obama quien a mini power and
three of our most commonly used
protocols there was county using a few
including the human microbiome project
frequency and exertion protocol the
mobile power solar kit and the suity and
extraction kit from coaching and as you
can see compared to a theoretical value
design the profile generated using our
kids is have almost perfect equipment
with the theoretical value while the
other three kids have dramatic buyers
and if you pay more attention you can
see that these three allocates
overestimate the abundance of easy to
relies organisms such as grow negative
organisms including Salmonella
sumner enterica ecoli and Pseudomonas
aeruginosa and they also under athlete's
under estimate the abundance of some
totalized organisms contained in the
standard mostly core negative ones are
for example these they were more
hydrogen and step out of caucus aureus
and Enterococcus for carrots
so if we do the same comparison by using
a wheel feces sample this is how the
profile would look like so if you assume
the profile generated using as a mobile
McMichael are tamo by omics the
dominican is more close to a wheel
composition of the PC sample then the
other three protocols over asked me they
overestimate the abundance of
Proteobacteria and bacterial royalties
and underestimate the abundance of
filmmakers and actinobacteria and
coincidently Proteobacteria and bacteria
deers are mostly connective
easier to rise and Firmicutes and
Actinobacteria are mostly a gram
positive top to rise
so this graph basically shows the same
trend as we shown in a comparison using
the demo controls so next I would I will
give a particular example about lighting
our bacterial endospores in this case we
compel we look into how mechanical ices
can can lies of bacteria endospores
so in this experiment we use the
endospores from the procedures of
today's and let it go through a my
critical Isis using the Z are bashing
B's license field which has a mixture of
point one and point five millimeter
piece and this feeding tubes is used as
part of the syma barovik DNA miniprep
and in a k so basically a suspension of
in disposed of procedures of today's
consumer chemical isis one with
mechanical isis and the other one
without mechanical isis the lysis was
performed of five minutes on the first
prep MP pass / 24 and through this
experiment we found out more than 99% of
the spots for lies however not all
mechanical Isis appear
identical so this video shows the
comparison of our DNA trinket with the
power so your kit and you can see the
yield the license efficiency and also
subsequently the DNA year it's much
lower with the mobile car with their
cotton of house oil kit so after this I
will talk about adjusting buyers in
during likely preparation process here
we use the sickness likely preparation
as an example the source of artifacts in
sickness sequencing include a PCR camera
reagent process contamination sample
causes cross contamination battle
contamination might seek run to run
carryover PCR errors sequencing errors
etc the defining composition of
microbiome standard is really helpful
based on my experience to help you
identify these artifacts and optimize
the likely preparation process so in
this case we're using the demo by open
microbial community the standard as the
defined input so this figure shows the
microbial composition of the enzyme
Obama microbial community standard when
sequencing and when sequence and analyze
using a regular workflow and as many as
43 bacterial general will identify while
the microbial community standard should
only have a bacterial genera so after a
theory of a series of optimization this
ISM
up to a serious optimization this is the
profile country
we have when using an optimized workflow
and only a bacterial general identified
which is almost perfectly with the
theoretical composition of the standard
another problem with 16s sequencing is
the limit coverage of the common 16s
primer
researchers commonly using a beer so we
also try to improve the ecology of these
primers so we go ahead and we we do we
design the primers based on the most
current reference database so in this
case we optimize the primers sickness
primers for v3 and v4 region so as in
unison as in my know the comment our v6
v3 v4 primers only covers the domain of
bacteria and has no coverage for either
archaea of eukaryotes and we we go and
we design the primers and manage to
expand the coverage to cover the
majority of archaea this is the red
columns indicates the coverage of our
current our primers and at the same time
we also improve a coverage for major
phyla
that is a four major bacterial fighters
as well which was shown in this figure
so in the end I would like to introduce
a new microbiome standard that are
coming them we are going to release soon
that will help you to assess both the
accuracy and detection limits of your
NGS workflows
this this standard is called as a mobile
McMichael community standard to with log
distribution so basically this standard
contains ten different organisms and
large distributed abundance the
horizontal axis of this graph shows the
theoretical abundance of different
organisms containing the standard and
the vertical line shows the NGS measured
abundance and as you can see the
agreement between the theoretical
abundance already funded bundles with
the NGS major abundance is almost
perfect
this indicates two things one is the
accuracy of the theoretical abundance
and the other one is the accuracy of our
NGS measurements so this
so using this micro balanced and o we
one can assess the performance of 16s
workflow so in this case we choose the
results with using the standard two to
assess the workflow of two are different
our our sickness work folks this
workflow is differ in the bioinformatics
analysis one uses charm and the other
use our data too and the conclusion is
the result coming from data to seems to
be more accurate as hidden it has um it
has no of us phosphates while that
Louisa coming from time has about nine
are false positives however the result
coming from charm seemed to have higher
sensitivity as it was able to detect the
presence of lactobacillus momentum while
our data to cannot in this particular
case this sender can also be used to
assess the performance of different
shotgun metagenomic workflows so in this
case we compare the performance of three
different our our bioinformatics our
pipelines used for shotgun metagenomics
so as shown in this figure we found that
this this three different of these three
different our pipelines have similar our
detection limit they all detect down to
the organism elective lactobacillus
Tormentum but the metafile m2 and the
commercial program x have identified
some false positives
while the MLT the the pipeline of MTU um
did not find Dino find any false
positives yeah
so so in the end I would like to
highlight some of our efforts which
trying to improve the accuracy of the
microbial measurements and all of these
efforts in the m was coming or was in
the end was in the end generated a
complete portfolio for micro bombing
measurements so in the end I would like
to thank all my colleagues from Xiamen
research especially to our director dr.
Larry jar for our D department and our
director of the nucleic acid fabrication
department our wine camp and thank you
and I can take questions from here
thank you dr. mason and dr. tank for
your presentation a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. Mason and dr. Tang will answer as
many questions as time permits the first
question is going to be for dr. Tang in
the comparison of human gut microbiome
profiles between HIV and metahit which
profile do you think is more accurate
okay arm so for this question I think
it's actually difficult to compare two
different DNA testing kids using a wheel
PC sample that have unknown composition
with such a comparison you can only see
the profile coming out from the two
expression kids are different based on
what I shown earlier in the presentation
we concluded that the HMP
the human microbiome object en
extraction protocol is actually
dramatically bias there was easy flies
microbes such as bacteria ideas in the
car microbiome I cannot comment on the
performance of the DNA testing team from
the men ahead because we do not include
that in our study but the metahit
protocols
seems to be based on my own opinion
seems to be more accurate although the
workflow
seems less streamer so I hope that
answered question great our second
question is going to be for dr. Mason
how much do long reads verse short reads
help for the controls yeah we've seen
that the longer the reads are definitely
the better so you can get much more
unambiguous taxonomic assignment when
you have the longer beads whether it's
single molecule reads or linked long
reads we've seen a lot better potential
in those long rates for mapping so if we
can get them we prefer them our next
question is going to be for dr. ting why
are bacteria more attracted by free saw
cycling than others how is DNA RNA field
able to protect microbiome profiles from
bias caused by free thought cycling um
okay up so free so cycling has lonely
long whilst damaged cells and in some
applications of we saw cycling is
actually a way people use to break down
biomass and we know that your royalties
are bacteria ideas are most mostly a
grand active with fragile cell wall and
I have a hypothesis i hypothesized that
priests or cycling can actually life
spec T avoidy cells and we lease their
DNA which is then degraded by actual
cellular DNA sees that are present in VC
samples so DNA initio can actually at
least work by protecting the release DNA
from the degradation of DNA cysts and
our next question is going to be for dr.
Mason do you think more seated in
people's answers so I think we've seen a
lot of controls for bacteria and also
for fungal species but I think
absolutely there's a lot of
mystery still on how you get accurate
parasite identification or other species
obviously plants can very complicated
even be a multi employee so you get a
box to plate species can complicate some
of the measurements so definitely when
you get into more broader looks at
what's an environmental samples or
complex clinical samples I think more
species will be better okay and dr.
tangle how do you control and reduce
false positives in taxonomy
identification given actually for
opinion well that was posted came from
um taking chemical on our we PRI member
sequencing arms like index swapping
artifacts artifacts in the sequence none
impedance analysis and also petitions
always open state amount data so an
effective way to have identify and
control cross positive is that we most
reliable or my bond standard is funny in
fact if you know opals in and you think
what was that and dr. Mason how about
RNA methylation yeah one thing we only
discuss briefly today is that the RNAs
and RNA virus is particular in actually
almost all our names we've ever looked
at have different levels of RNA
methylation so this is another area a
future work that I think will be
interesting to develop in the microbiome
and metagenomic space or through the
meta transcriptomic space so it's a new
area of research that we and a lot of us
started to look at and it's a pretty
exciting because a lot of still unknown
and we do have time for one more
question
dr. ting what steps in a microbiome is
or metagenomics will flow and affect the
detection
I choose from any step in what has the
potential to affect the detection limit
then Bonzo will choose all bomb by
automatic pipelines curve effective
detection limits estimate studies of the
different fear also insufficient our
wisest doing DNS fiction can become an
enema its efficiency the devil because
in quality and also the detection limits
there's a lot of examples actors since
there are no more questions I would like
to once again thank the free thing and
dr. King for their presentations do you
have any final comment I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions we would
like to thank our sponsors and Research
Corporation for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through July 2018
labret swill alerts you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye